place à l'actualité politique du jour le
sénat examine depuis cet après midi le
projet de loi sanitaire du gouvernement
celui qui avait été amputé la semaine
dernière à l'assemblée nationale la
droite qui domine le sénat se retrouve
en position de force pour imposer ses
vues ces orientations à quoi ressemble
le nouveau texte auquel point avec ses
cimes section
sortie du texte par l'assemblée
nationale l'article 2 qui prévoit le
contrôle sanitaire aux frontières a été
réintroduit dans la copie des sénateurs
une décision saluée par le ministre de
la santé lors de la discussion générale
je me félicite que la commission des
lois est confirmé le principe de
l'intérêt de cette disposition je salue
l'esprit de responsabilité qui a prévalu
pas question pour autant de reprendre
tel quel l'article initialement rédigé
par le gouvernement les sénateurs
prévoit d'obliger les voyageurs a
présenté un test négatif aux frontières
en cas de reprise de l'épidémie avec un
variant dangereux un compromis pour
philippe bas le rapporteur du texte
entre la position du gouvernement et
celle de l'assemblée nationale c'est une
mesure en réalité de souplesse par
rapport aux moyens brutaux que l'état
pourrait mettre en oeuvre si cette
mesure n'existait pas elle est virtuel
il est improbable qu'elle est à être
mises en oeuvre mais si elle doit être
mise en oeuvre alors il faudra le faire
de toute urgence c'est la raison pour
laquelle elles doivent figurer dans le
texte outre modifications dans sa
version du texte le sénat met fin au
dispositif de restriction des libertés
est inscrit moins sur blanc la fin de
l'état d'urgence dire que demain le
gouvernement ne pourra plus mobilisé
deux dispositions pour faire un
confinement un couvre-feu ou bien un
pass sanitaires ou bien un pass
vaccinale c'est fini le gouvernement ne
prévoyait pas d'abroger des textes qui
créent ces dispositifs nous l'avons fait
enfin le texte ouvre la porte à une
réintégration des soignants non vaccinés
en fonction de l'évolution de l'épidémie
mais sur les bancs de la gauche on reste
opposé à sourire nous avons toujours
considéré qu'il n'était pas normal que
des médecins et personnels soignants
soit contre les vaccins parce que les
vaccins ont sauvé des millions et des
millions de vie depuis de nombreuses
décennies dans le monde donc nous sommes
pour le principe de l'obligation
vaccinale pour les personnels médicaux
qui travaillent dans les hôpitaux si le
texte est voté ce soir demain les
sénateurs devront s'accorder sur une
version commune avec les députés
ce nouveau projet de loi sanitaire on en
parle ce soir avec mes invités marion
parler des bons soirs vous êtes
secrétaire générale et fondatrice du
cercle de réflexion le millénaire je me
suis pas trompé c'est à dire ça janek
j'accueille également jean-pierre
mignard docteur en droit et avocat au
barreau de paris à vos côtés jean daniel
lévy directeur délégué de l'institut
harris interactive france et puis
guillaume daret genre genre de l'éthique
dont l'oeil affûté et le verbe bien
placé
mme accompagneront tout au long de
l'émission alors on l'a compris c'est la
fin de l'état d'urgence sanitaire le 31
juillet et ce texte remanié par le sénat
marque la fin définitif est quasiment un
pléonasme selon les mots de philippe bas
de toute mesure d'exception limitant les
déplacements confinement couvre-feu
envie d'aller faire allusion du point de
vue des libertés publiques jean pierre
mignard est ce qu'il était temps pour le
moins oui c'est un vrai progrès quand
même parce qu'on était dans une
situation où l'état d'exception devenait
l'état ordinaire c'était vraiment pas
possible et puis ça obligera si vraiment
des mesures ou des dispositifs plus
contraignant devaient être pris à
s'expliquer ça obligera effectivement à
ce que le parlement dans sa dernière
dans son dispositif nouveau soient
menées effectivement à tout appréhendé
je pense que c'est bien pour tout le
monde y compris pour le gouvernement que
ça va être à l'abri des tentations
d'avoir un très rapidement considéré que
tout est facile on reprend une mesure
non non je trouve que c'est un grand
progrès sur le plan des des libertés ça
fait quand même un sacré bout de temps
qu'on vit sous un régime d'état du reste
si on cumule l'état d'urgence terroriste
puis état d'urgence comme on s'habitue à
comme qu'on s'habitue et insensiblement
on s'habitue et donc ses parts il
faudrait d'ailleurs avoir démontré que
cette habitude cette continuité dans le
temps
montrez une véritable efficacité c'est
pas vrai une efficacité dans l'habitude
la facilité et le confort parce que ça
existe mais ça vous met à l'abri de
devoir dans certains cas explicite et
pourquoi on reprend des mesures de
contrainte humains contre les mesures de
contrainte mais sous parlement quand
même 2 d'apprécier si elles doivent ou
non être prises alors je vais me faire
l'avocat du diable est ce que c'est bien
prudent je pense que c'est au contraire
un très bon signal je rejoins un
monsieur dans ses propos mais sur le
plan politique et sur le plan social
alors parloir du plan sanitaire vous
voilà sur le plan sanitaire c'est autre
chose on peut discuter mais ça dépendra
réellement de l'avancée de l'épidémie et
de l'évolution du virus est ce qu il
reprend sa forme très dangereuse et avec
des formes graves ou pas mais dans
l'état actuel des choses il y avait
réellement une crainte qui était
exprimée lors des manifestations anti
passe sommes pas des anti vague se parle
bien des antilles pas beaucoup de
personnes qui étaient pro vaccination
mais qu'ils n'acceptaient pas en fait
cet état d'urgence par crainte justement
de ne pas savoir jusqu'où ça pouvait
aller ou quelle serait la fin et est ce
que finalement un jour on y mettrait une
fin donc là on vient en fait finalement
donné rassurer toutes ces personnes qui
jusqu'à maintenant ont commencé à se
questionner sur la nature même de la
démocratie en france est-ce qu'on est
réellement dans une démocratie si on est
dans une dictature gouvernement
qui incitait aussi à une certaine forme
de complotisme donc c'est tout ce dont
vous devez le débat public au exactement
ce appelons ça a plombé pendant
longtemps débat public entre les deux il
ya eu en plus sa crise en ukraine qui
s'est rajouté dessus donc ça ça a été un
peu étouffée mais c'était encore très
présent en fin d'année dernière même en
janvier
donc aujourd'hui on avance là-dessus on
envoie un signal positif en disant non
on est capable de revenir dessus on est
toujours dans une démocratie et ça se
fait à travers le travail du parlement
donc c'est encore mieux parce que ça
montre qu'il ya vraiment un dialogue qui
peut s'instaurer entre l'exécutif et le
gouvernement jordan élèves les français
n'en pouvait plus de toutes ces mesures
pas du tout haha tu ne sais pas si c'est
un vrai débat c'est un débat qui est je
trouve extrêmement intéressant et un
débat qui qui est tout à fait fondée
mais en fait on a quand même une peur
existe et que la peur aujourd'hui a
tendance à annihiler un certain nombre
de représentations la part des individus
notamment l'aspiration à l'égard de la
liberté quand bien même je ferai partie
de notre devise républicaine parce que
vous l'avez un symbole historique depuis
le début de la pandémie les mesures
raison plutôt été acceptée par l'opinion
elles ont été acceptées elles ont été
respectées et les français qui souvent
sont décrits comme étant un peuple
frondeur ou éventuellement qui cherchent
à chercher nous trouver en fait la
tangente pour éviter de respecter les
règles sont très profondément respecté
la plupart des règles ont été édictées
et même en fait les comparaisons qu'on
peut être fait au niveau européen ne
serait ce que par exemple par la place
de confinement ou avec les smartphones
vous pouvez voir globalement si les
français ou les européens se déplacer on
voyait bien que les français contre
intuitive en était par exemple bien plus
disciplinés que ne pouvait l'être nos
amis allemands donc on a des débats des
interprétations qui ont complètement
volé en éclats on avait déjà eu en fait
il ya quelques années un premier signal
où on voyait bien que dans les processus
de profondes interrogations étaient
prêts à restreindre sur l'aspiration à
la liberté on accepter un contrôle accru
voire démesurée de la part de l'état au
moment par exemple des attaques
terroristes et lorsqu'il ya eu un
contrôle qui a été effectuée de la part
de l'état de la consultation des sites
internet etc alors que les français sont
férus justement de ce type de recours il
avait accepté le fait qu'il puisse y
avoir ce type de mesure lorsqu'il ya eu
en fait des mesures administratives
étaient pas forcément des mesures
judiciaires là aussi au nom de l'urgence
est au nom de la gravité il ya eu dans
l'immense majorité de la population
l'acceptation de ce principe là et se
débat aujourd'hui sur l'état d'urgence
sanitaire a eu une résidence une
résonance pardon auprès de franges de
population mais chalmé n'a pas été enfin
les franges qui étaient les plus à
gauche et celle qui pour faire vite et
les plus à droite voire proches de ceux
qui ont été décrits comme étant les
mouvements des dg les jaunes mais pour
l'heure
ce soir c'est que la majorité des
français ne considèrent pas convenu en
dictature nos régimes non à ce niveau-là
pas ce niveau là et il ya même eu en
fait une interrogation sur le conseil
national de défense en fait avec le fait
qu'on n'ait pas de connaissance de la
nature des délibérés des informations
qui étaient délivrés ou voir même des
décisions qui pouvaient en découler au
final aux attaques de jean luc mélenchon
oui mais qui n'a pas eu d'incidence
extrêmement fortes de la part de nos
compatriotes à cet égard là donc fin et
et peut-être que le débat d'ailleurs
resté circonscrit comme vous l'avait
indiqué au tour de jean luc mélenchon
politiquement et pas forcément face à
d'autres acteurs et c'est peut-être une
des raisons pour lesquelles ça a pas eu
plus d'incidence d'un point de vue
général d'opinion alors le texte des
sénateurs fait un distinguo entre
l'hexagone et les territoires
ultramarins en cas de saturation de
leurs établissements de santé c'est au
reste du point de vue des principes
parce que c'est acceptable ou non la
plénière non non je pense vraiment qu'il
ya une continuité c'est la république
d'alors c'est la république sur le plan
du principe politique il ya une
continuité un là elle est évidente et
puis surtout ça signifie si on réfléchit
bien que en fait nous ne validons pas le
niveau des normes sanitaires des la
qualité des soins qui sont apportées
dans les territoires ultramarins c'est
télé parce que le regard obvier qui est
porté sur notre action sanitaire est
péjoratif
alors c'est peut-être pas efficace mais
alors faisons en sorte que ce soit
efficace plutôt que de prendre acte
d'une inégalité qui est peut-être dans
les fêtes mais qu' on vient soudain
transcrire dans la norme il a c'est un
vrai il y avait déjà une différenciation
moment de l'obligation de la mise en
place de l'obligation pour les soignants
il avait eu un report de quelques
semaines si je me trouve à faire dans
l'exacte est parfaitement exact donc on
ya une discrimination alors je veux pas
me placer sur plan des principes on te
voit pas de sens mais on voit bien qu'il
n'y a pas égalité des infrastructures de
prise en charge des soins de prévention
est donc très bien ça se traduit par une
discrimination ça me semble alors là
pour le coup un vrai vrai vrai sujet et
c'est attaquable ah bah oui tout est
attaquable ce qui veut dire que l'avocat
qui parle ce qui est intéressant c'est
que le débat sur les principes peut
aussi faire évoluer très profondément le
rapport des français à un somme de
comportement ou de politiques publiques
qui peuvent être déployées je me
rappelle que vu la scène stan lee avait
été stigmatisé comme étant un
département
globalement avec des populations qui
suit pas vraiment là les vagues et puis
en quelques semaines on a eu une
évolution considérable autour justement
du taux d'équipement en termes de
structures sanitaires on présente en
seine saint denis et une évolution très
profonde de la part de nos compatriotes
qui ont qui sont passés en fait de la
stigmatisation à la compassion voire
même à l'exigence et en considérant que
la république avait une responsabilité
et qu'il devait y avoir une présence sur
des territoires qui étaient les
territoires moins bien équipés comme la
seine-saint-denis et que dans ce
contexte là si jamais il y avait une
augmentation importante des
contaminations ou des risques dans ce
département là c'était pas forcément à
la fois des individus mais ça interpellé
si on peut inviter cette expression la
réplique dans son organisation alors on
ne parle plus d'eux on ne parle plus de
passes sanitaires on parle désormais de
certificats sanitaires de voyage est ce
qu'on est en train de jouer sur les mots
guillaume ci parce qu'on voit que
justement dans ces franges de la
population ou d'activistes politiques me
par exemple florian philippot qu'on voit
toujours très actif sur les réseaux
sociaux ces derniers jours on voit que
pour eux ça ne change rien ils sont en
train de dire toujours sous cette
logique complotistes regarder finalement
si j'ose dire familièrement on essayait
de nous refourguer le pass sanitaire
sous un autre nom et ce sera la même
chose et ce qui est intéressant dans ce
que disait jean daniel c'est que moi
j'ai entendu à plusieurs reprises
emmanuel macron
dire en marge de déplacement qu'il avait
été étonné durant les confinements
successifs de la faible contestation
sur le terrain de la grande discipline
des français y compris
de la part de ce qu'ils remontaient des
forces de sécurité surveillance du
territoire parce que lui-même concédait
c'était évidemment des mesures de
restriction extrêmement forte absolument
inédite et qui s'attendaient
politiquement à ce qui est des mesures
beaucoup plus importantes pour ce qui
est des modifications qui sont faites
aujourd'hui je trouve que dans l'
équilibre politique aider les
contestations et des oppositions au
pouvoir il ya une chose intéressante à
relever qui montre un peu l'évolution si
les clips politiques de ces dernières
semaines c'est l'attitude des
républicains qui pour certains réclament
la réintégration d'une partie des
personnels soignants non vaccinés si je
dis pas de bêtises les pompiers en
particulier ce qui est quand même un
changement notable de la part d'un parti
qui se dit toujours un parti de
gouvernement rappelle que c'était une
promesse présidentielle de marine le pen
et de genres douteuse gens alors qu'une
personne christian jacob qui n'est plus
à la tête des républicains
était extrêmement ferme sur l'obligation
vaccinale des soignants comment vous
l'interprétez ce bouge et
ça montre la difficulté je trouve des
républicains situé dans le débat actuel
c'est-à-dire coin c'est effectivement
une partie de la radicalité que ce soit
de la nuque ou du rassemblement national
et finalement de la fermeté politique de
la majorité qui joue la responsabilité
sanitaire mais je trouve que c'est assez
symbolique de la difficulté des
républicains à se positionner
aujourd'hui dans le débat public ça pose
un problème d'exemplarité de réintégrer
ce soignant alors pour le coup je ne
partage pas du tout votre opinion parce
que justement la question de la
vaccination des soignants elle est plus
du tout la même aujourd'hui qu'elle ne
l'était en 2021 au moment où on a
commencé la vaccination est ce qu on a
commencé la vaccination en se disant ça
freine la propagation et ça évite les
cas graves chez les personnes qui sont
vaccinées or aujourd'hui avec les
évolutions du virus et les nombreux cas
qui se multiplient malgré la vaccination
on peut globalement se dire que l'effet
sur la propagation est assez limité or
dans ce cas là la question se pose
d'aidés soignants justement au goût des
pompiers en l'occurrence est ce que il
est vraiment légitime de continuer à les
tenir hors de leur milieu de travail
alors qu'on est sur un million qui en
souffrance l'hôpital avec un effet de
fatigue etc alors qu'ils peuvent être au
service et qu'au final ils vont surtout
risqué leur propre santé puisque de
toute façon la propagation n'est pas a
priori
empêché par le fait d'être est vacciné
donc les seigneurs ferme opposition à ce
revirement sur la question de
l'intégration ou non des personnels
soignants non vaccinés et je vous
propose d'écouter tient pour rebondir
sur sous vous disiez ce qu'on disait ce
matin sur france info l'urgentiste
mathias wargon c'est ridicule parce que
ça ça mais un énorme doute sur la
vaccination c'est ridicule et c'est
dangereux parce que ça veut dire que la
prochaine fois qu'on demandera au
personnel de se vacciner on dira aux
jambes a finalement que vous faites
signer ou pas ça n'a aucune importance
je vous rappelle quand même que ces gens
qui sont anti vaccins et on peut
discuter de l'efficacité du vaccin
actuellement on refusait de se faire
vacciner à un moment vaccin était
efficace un moment où c'était
extrêmement important à la fois pour nos
patients à la fois pour nous est à la
fois pour le maintien de l'hôpital
public donc tous les gens comme là elle
est fille comme le fn qui veulent la fin
de la vaccination veulent la fin de
l'hôpital public en réalité il a raison
jean pierre mignard ça pose un problème
d'exemplarité oui ça pose un problème
d'exemplarité
c'est certain si par exemple je
reprenais d'ailleurs la rédaction du
sénat d'ailleurs intéressant c'est
jésuitique d'ailleurs monsieur on a
introduit l'idée de variants dangereux
et surviendrait 1 ça suppose qu'en effet
on pose
je dirais constat de ce que mario est
nouveau et qu'il est très dangereux et
qui met en oeuvre un processus
qui était décrit par philippe bas
deuxièmement ça va reposer la question
effectivement de des personnels
soignants est ce qu'il ya une autre
nouvelle dose létale à l'immense
majorité s'y pliera d'ailleurs et c'est
plié aujourd'hui à plus c'est plus un
très grand nombre d'infirmiers ni de
médecins douze mille personnes environ
beaucoup moins semblerait que ce soit
beaucoup moins de surcroît dans le
silence conseil national de l'ordre des
infirmiers infirmières a joué un rôle
important en terme de médiation donc on
n'est plus du tout dans les données
chiffrées du départ avec aujourd'hui en
effet une maladie qui apparaît peut-être
moins létale est moins dangereuse
qu'elle ne l'était avant c'est vrai vous
avez raison contient un vaccin ya vaccin
canton
c'est très délicat de dire non est ce
que le vaccin doit être complètement est
toujours efficace non mais est ce que le
fait que le vaccin est sur ce point le
moyen supplémentaire le seul dont on
dispose pour se mettre à l'abri oui mais
c'est vrai pour tout traitement
n'importe quel traitement aucun
traitement n'est certain de réussir eux
le savent bien ce sont des
professionnels donc je crois que je
crois faut pas brûler après faut pas
stigmatiser mais honnêtement on peut pas
céder parce que si on set je ne sais pas
très bien on arrive sur ce point la
jordanie a annoncé ce que ce que pensent
les français de cette question là d'une
manière générale quand on remonte à tout
petit peu en amont nous on a toujours
considéré que le pass sanitaire n'était
pas uniquement de passer un test et au 6
impasse sociale c'est à dire les
français qui disait j'ai pris le risque
entre guillemets de me faire vacciner et
il n'est pas normal que les personnes
qui n'ont pas pris ce risque là et les
mêmes droite moi et donc le fait qu'il
puisse y avoir une responsabilité de la
part des individus qui accorde un soin
de droit était une dimension absolument
central et à éviter je pense qui est une
tension qui se dit c'est que ce soit vu
sur ajouter à celle qu'on a pu connaître
qui aurait pu traverser l'ensemble de la
population française est donc dans ce
contexte là on attend de la part des
soignants que il montre l'exemple et que
cette dimension d'exemple c'est de
suivre un protocole qui est un protocole
de vaccination aujourd'hui le débat
s'est pas est ce que le vaccin est
dangereux ou pas c est ce que le vaccin
est efficace ou n'est pas efficace et
c'est pas du du tout le même registre ou
non ce contexte là on n'a pas le
sentiment qu'on va se mettre en danger
en se faisant vacciner on souhaite et on
considère d'une poignée moss majorité
que le personnel soignant dans sa
totalité sur connaissent en fait cet
épisode vaccinale pour pouvoir protéger
les autres et pas uniquement se protéger
soi même ajoutons qu'il s'agit de la
protection des personnels soignants
aussi dénis personnel soignant ne s'agit
de leur protection deuxièmement dans ce
mois dans un établissement de soins
quels qu'ils soient privés ou publics
évident que l'établissement engage sa
responsabilité vis-à-vis des personnes
qui sont accueillis notamment et doit
s'assurer de la fiabilité optimale de
son personnel donc protection des
soignants et de tous les soignants de
cela compris lorsqu'ils sont réticents
mais enfin bon un peu con on peut les
convaincre beaucoup ont été convaincus
ou pas non plus effectivement qu'on
dramatise trop cette cette situation et
puis deuxièmement c'est la
responsabilité des établissements soient
ils ne peuvent pas dérogé à sa alors si
on regarde ce projet de loi sanitaire
d'un point de vue un petit peu plus
politique politiciens j'allais dire
c'est pas un paradoxe guillaume d'avoir
vu que les députés aient l'air voté
contre le texte et les sénateurs à l'air
retricoter derrière un texte qui
ressemble fort au premier c'est ce qu'on
faisait avant c'est le comment va se
positionner le parti des républicains et
finalement on voit bien effectivement le
le petit jeu auquel va se prêter
notamment la majorité le gouvernement et
puis directement emmanuel macron je
pense que vous l'avez encore davantage
entendu que moi ici dans les couloirs du
sénat c'est clairement emmanuel macron a
décidé de jouer le sénat avant de jouer
l'assemblée en particulier pour les
républicains c'est à dire faire venir
des textes peut-être pas qui était prévu
au début au sénat par le sénat trouver
un accord avec la droite la majorité
sénatoriale avec la droite sénatoriale
effet revenir ensuite ce texte à
l'assemblée nationale et dire au député
maire c'est quand même compliqué pour
vous d'aller modifiée de voter un texte
différent de ce qu'on fait vos amis au
sénat donc c'est là où on voit en partie
emmanuel macron n'a pas totalement perdu
son habileté politique mais les
sénateurs de droite vont s'y prêter ils
vont sauver la mise du gouvernement
d'une certaine façon ils vont sauver la
mise au gouvernement mais ils seront je
pense assez heureux de montrer que le
sénat sert à quelque chose qu'ils ont un
rôle absolument fondamental
et que dans un premier temps
comme disait ségolène royal ce sera un
peu gagnant gagnant donc et qu'on voit
bien en plus qu'au sein du groupe l'est
républicain à l'assemblée nationale il
n'y a pas une ligne il y en a plusieurs
alors on va faire justement le point sur
les républicains à l'assemblée nationale
parce que pendant que le sénat travaille
et réécrit le texte sanitaires et et en
discutent depuis cet après midi là bas
les députés aient l'air donne quelques
signes d'ouverture sur le texte pouvoir
d'achat au palais bourbon en faire le
point sur les avancées les concessions
avec steve jourdain steve cette semaine
de part tenant se penche donc sur les
mesures du gouvernement sur le pouvoir
d'achat il ya 1 3 qui fait l'objet de
tractations très politique en coulisses
c'est la question des carburants et la
question des carburants elle sera
discutée dans un texte dont l'examen est
prévu à partir de demain à l'assemblée
nationale il s'agit d'une disposition
qui figure dans le projet de loi de
finances rectificative et c'est l'une
des mesures très symboliques de ce
paquet pouvoir d'achat proposée par le
gouvernement on va rappeler mathieu les
positions des uns et des autres côté
gouvernement on propose de prolonger la
remise de 18 centimes à la pompe mise en
place depuis le 1er avril une
prolongation qui restent jusqu'à cet
automne avec une baisse progressive à
partir du mois d'octobre
en complément l'exécutif veut mettre en
place une indemnité spécifique pour les
ménages les plus défavorisés et les gros
rouleurs côté lr officiellement pas
question de voter précisément ce chèque
carburant on propose plutôt de garantir
un prix du carburant à la pompe à 1 euro
50 par litre on rappelle qu'il avoisine
actuellement les deux euros pour
financer cette mesure les alertes
propose de supprimer et de réduire les
taxes sur les énergies mais bono le
maire avait dit que c'était beaucoup
trop cher ça c'est pour les positions de
principe mais dans les faits est-ce
qu'il ya le début d'un compromis on
voyait mal comment on va écouter
holliger barre l'ex ce matin sur france
info le président du groupe plr à
l'assemblée nationale confirme que les
discussions avancées qu'elles avancent
bien écouter on est en train de discuter
de tout ça l'est de 18 centimes elle
devait s'arrêter
la rentrée peut pas laisser nos deux
compatriotes sans solution nous à nous
proposer quelque chose qui ressemblait
un peu trop à une usine à gaz je me suis
entretenue avec la première ministre qui
fait a fait preuve d' écoutes qui voilà
qui qui dès qu'ils souhaitent qui a
besoin que le projet de finances
rectificative il ya le projet leur
pouvoir d'achat y jeu de finances
rectificative
soit adopté donc oui j'ai bon espoir que
qu'on arrive à s'entendre alors pour
l'instant les contours d'un éventuel
compromis est leur majorité
présidentielle sur le carburant est
encore flou mais ça pourrait passer
pourquoi pas par une augmentation et où
la prolongation de l'aide 18 centimes
d'euros jusqu'à la fin de l'année dans
cette équation le vent parlais tout à
l'heure il faut intégrer les sénateurs
aient leurs dessinateurs qui refusent la
solution de leurs camarades députés les
républicains sur les 1 euro 50 bref ce
qui va être intéressant savait devoir
qui chez les députés verts va saisir la
main tendue par le gouvernement ce texte
et ces mesures sur le carburant c'est un
texte pour l'exécutif évidemment oui
mais aussi peut-être surtout pour le
parti a l'air qui va devoir se trouver
un nouveau chef d'ici à cet hiver
mathieu merci steve et puis ya peut-être
d'autres restent aussi sur la
défiscalisation des heures
supplémentaires
marion parisien est ce que c'est un
dialogue durable qui est en train de
s'installer là où ce sont des
accommodements ponctuelle non mais y
avoir de toutes façons d accompagnement
ponctuel au cas par cas par projet
c'était l'ambition d'elisabeth bornes
elle a clairement annoncé depuis dakar
texte par tex et ce sera a priori le cas
il se trouve que là sur le premier une
tente peut-être je pense l'approchent la
plus facile qui est par le groupe élèves
mais c'est intéressant de mettre en
parallèle travail sur la loi sanitaire
et puis sur cette loi sur le paquet
pouvoir d'achat puisque ce qu'on voit
sur la loi sanitaire c'est que justement
l'assemblée nationale est un petit peu
aussi sur le pouvoir d'achat reste
vraiment aujourd'hui encore la chasse
gardée vraiment de la majorité
présidentielle qui veut garder une
position ferme garder un peu la main sur
la façon dont se déroule
l'avancé du texte et c'est ce qui s'est
vu avec le fait que finalement
l'opposition les oppositions
conjointement ont réussi à pouvoir
bloquer certains articles dans le cas de
la loi sanitaire sur l'article 2 mais
ils ne sont pas capables de s'allier
suffisamment pour pouvoir proposer des
amendements et de les faire passer
contre la majorité est donc aujourd'hui
sur le online est revenu sur les
premières les premiers échanges et eu
que très peu de choses qui sont très peu
d'amendements de l'opposition qui ont
été acceptés y en a eu deux il ya eu pcf
ayant un amendement de l air donc on est
encore sur quelque chose qui est quand
même loin de la discussion et du conte
preuve la recherche de compromis à
l'assemblée nationale et le rôle du
sénat pour le coût est important qu'il
n'a semblé beaucoup plus discrète
beaucoup moins visible même en termes de
communication du grand public et ça le
plus bel équilibre politique bien sûr
n'est pas le même cette alliance
majorité présidentielle heller et vous
paraît logique jean pierre est
inévitable alors l'ennui c'est que la 6e
d'accord sur les accotements partial
mais si à chaque fois c'est aussi
byzantin je doute en effet que nos
concitoyens vont retrouver un goût
immodéré pour la politique qui va
devenir quand même très vite et très peu
intelligible à la fin ils vont devoir
payer verrons bien ce qui baisse on n'y
comprend pas grand chose simplement que
tous ne prennent pas la même position
vis-à-vis de la majorité relative
d'aucuns peut-être parce qu'ils
souhaitent l'intégrer d'autre part ce
qu'il souhaite être un soutien
indispensable
troisièmement parce que je pense ce qui
vont le plus loin se disent que c'est le
deuxième et dernier mandat d'emmanuel
macron et que donc il faut peut-être
commencer dès maintenant une offre
publique d'achat lorsque je dis peut
sembler tout à fait intéressant mais
l'esprit politique est tellement bizarre
qu'en effet on peut se projeter très
loin finalement tous les groupes tous
les leaders de succession possible un
jeu je vois pas ce qu'on peut avoir des
tas de catastrophes depuis regarder on a
même les cendres des feux des landes et
de gironde qui arrivent chez nous donc
je ne sais pas de quoi demain sera fait
mais peuvent se dire ce sera dans la
famille et l'air que il y aura un
candidat ou une candidate il sera
susceptible les rifains de rafler la
mise la mise est en renaissance voilà ce
que je crois donc tout ça va énormément
joué il va faire que si on veut discuter
en vérité sur telle ou telle disposition
intérêt général seront et pour certaines
d'avoir du mal à comprendre si on ne
sait pas qu untel et untel et c'est
byzance
on a beaucoup lu ou entendu que les
français par leur vote avait demandé aux
parties de se mettre d'accord de
gouverner ensemble est ce que c'est
votre sentiment moi c'est parce que j'ai
c'est parce que j'ai lu dans le cadre de
nos études quand vous regardez
globalement en fait les électeurs qui
ont voté pour la nuque c'est ce qu'on
m'a dit ben on va voter pour la venue
pour partie fils y avoir une alliance
avec la formation ou les formations qui
sont proches des manuels macron les
électeurs qui ont voté pour le rapport
national pas une seule seconde se sont
dits heureux soit un gouvernement
d'union nationale au sein duquel en fait
les membres du rrn pour être présent ou
alors oui pour y avoir des éléments de
cohérence de projets dès lors quand vous
regardez les motivations de vote elles
sont là pour le coup assez orthogonale
quand vous regardez les électeurs qui
ont voté pour les réplicants ils sont un
peu plus ambiguë mais globalement en
fait grâce aux deux thématiques la
reconnaissance de la valeur travail le
rapport à la liberté le rapport à
l'autorité le rapport globalement en
fait même à la sécurité on a des
positions qui sont des positions qui
sont plus tendus que celles qui sont
aujourd'hui portés de la part des
électeurs de deux renaissance les seuls
entre guillemets qui était prêt
potentiellement à l'ouverture c'est ce
qu'ils ont donné une majorité relative
c'est à dire ce qu ont voté pour la
formation politique et proche du
président de la réplique à la après est
ce que ça veut dire que globalement il
peut pas y avoir des accords s'il peut y
aura des accords et ya eu l'idée de se
dire qu' on n'est pas forcément dans
l'opposition systématique il peut y
avoir des points sur lesquels il peut y
avoir des dimensions de convergence qui
sont portées de la part des élus
demandent qu'à le mandat n'a pas été
dire eh bien on va vous créer une
chambre ingouvernable mais on va vous
demander quand même de trouver vous même
les conditions pour qu'il puisse y avoir
une forme de sortie de crise une forme
de cohérence on reste un pic politique
on reste un pays qui se nourrit en
général de la conflictuelles et et
politique beaucoup plus que le consensus
culture de lanta saison on est dans
cette culture là notamment lorsqu'on
regarde par rapport à nos voisins
allemands et ne serait ce que dans notre
jeu institutionnel avec absolue
majoritaire qui fait face dans
l'opposition vous n'avez rien
guillaume est ce qu'une ligne chez air
sur le deal ou non avec mâcon est ce que
ça a évolué ce que vous avez senti des
choses bouger depuis le 19 juin au soir
moi je sens quelque chose bougeait déjà
quand on entend livier par l'ex qui est
quand même réputé pour être un pur et
dur depuis trois semaines qui ont leur
lot coeur d'aller voir ce que l'on était
un vrai réquisitoire qui on l'entend il
ya quelques secondes dit je me suis
entretenue avec la première ministre qui
a fait preuve d' écoute et avec qui on
peut discuter c'est pas exactement le
même discours qu'on avait il ya deux
trois semaines et moi j'ai plusieurs
parlementaires que ce soit des députés
ou des sénateurs
les républicains qui me disent
d'ailleurs est bien la première ministre
c'est pas mal depuis trois semaines on
peut échanger elle nous appelle ses
premières semaines c'est plutôt réussi
je trouve pour les abeilles bornes parce
qu'elles donnent le sentiment d'échangés
elle donne le sentiment de vouloir
négocier vous dire elle a pas vraiment
le choix mais c'est vrai qu'au sein des
républicains on sent quand même qu'il ya
une petite évolution probablement comme
le disait jean pierre mignard parce que
ils se disent qu'il faut davantage jouer
la responsabilité
pour la suite et puis peut-être on en
parlera je crois également qu à côté
d'eux ils ont 89 députés du
rassemblement national se joue la
responsabilité et qui ne demande qu'une
chose c'est de les croquer justement
trouver les voix qui lui manquent
sheller c'est aussi surtout un moyen
pour la majorité présidentielle mais de
refuser le baiser de la mort que lui
adresse le rassemblement national marine
le pen a elle même annoncé dès lundi
dernier que son groupe voterait le texte
pouvoir d'achat à l'assemblée nationale
c'est le grand arbitre d'une certaine
façon de deux des élégances le le
rassemblement se valent aujourd'hui
c'est leur tentative en tout cas c'est
exactement ce qui leur faut aujourd'hui
pour tenter de s'institutionnaliser et
de réussir vraiment marqué le pas et
passer le cap de la tolérance ont
finalement dans l'opinion publique est
de pouvoir devenir totalement acceptable
comme potentiel partis de gouvernement
puisque ça qu'il tente de faire donc
aujourd'hui ils ont aucun intérêt à se
positionner de manière plus radicale
vis-à-vis des les rênes la difficulté ça
va être sur le temps long est-ce qu'ils
vont réussir à maintenir cette position
parce que on sent déjà que les déçus de
reconquête ont potentiellement envie
aussi de retrouver à une nouvelle une
nouvelle vie avait gagné cette bataille
de la respectabilité dans l'opinion pour
le rassemblement national il est
beaucoup trop tôt il est beaucoup trop
tôt il s'est pas encore complètement
visible c'est à dire que on va en parler
ici sur ce plateau et on en parle
également par ailleurs on sait que ça
met du temps en fait d'une manière
générale pour les français pour se
rendre compte on fait de ce que peut
être clairement les prises de position
de la part des uns et des autres mais
enfin en tout cas c'est vrai qu'à
aujourd'hui un bruit médiatique qu'il
laisse entrevoir que ben on est face à
une surprise par rapport à la manière
dont un marine le pen et ses différents
candidats parlent c'est différent la
députée peuvent se positionner par
rapport au président a répliqué il ya
une donnée d'opinion qui a été peu
commenté en tout cas dans le cadre de
nous de notre dernier baromètre c'est
que quand vous interrogez sur la
confiance qui est exprimée à l'égard des
différents acteurs sur les 6 premiers
brevets trois qui sont proches soient du
ressort national soit de reconquête il
s'agit de marine le pen et il s'agit et
de marion maréchal il s'agit également
de jordan bardella tout ceci se passe
quand même dans un environnement
d'opinion où le niveau de confiance a
tendance à croître auprès de la plupart
des dirigeants qui sont des dirigeants
qui se situe le plus à droite sur
l'échiquier politique sans même que ça
ne suscite véritablement de débats ou
d'émotion de la part de ceux qui sont
pas proches de ses soutiens passé
edouard philippe la deuxième
personnalité hors au gouvernement à qui
les français à quand le poussent leur
confiance le confiance à ce n'est pas
une question de liberté d'opinion c'est
marine le pen c'est marine le pen avec
plus d'un tiers des français donc fausse
faut voir vraiment ce que peut être
cette modification profonde de pignan ça
veut dire que la critique du camp ma
chronique et d'emmanuel macron lui-même
d'ailleurs en premier sur le fait que
leur assemblée nationale ne serait pas
un pas gouvernement c'est quelque chose
qui est en train de devenir caduque non
seulement ça a tendance à devenir
caduque et même en fait un des registres
et à des registres de critiques à
l'égard du rassemblement national
c'était la question la compétence a
tendance à devenir aujourd'hui
complètement balayées d'un point de vue
d'opinion à la veille en fait du
deuxième tour de ne pas de langue du
débat d'entre deux tours on avait
réalisé une étude on voyait bien que
d'un point de vue d'opinion même marine
le pen est disputée à emmanuel macron la
capacité à point être compétente pour
être présidente de la réplique par
rapport au débat d'entre deux tours de
2017 on a pu voir la très profonde
évolution le chèque est effectuée lors
pas d'une semelle parcours où je reviens
vers vous guillaume c'est un piège pour
le gouvernement aujourd'hui le
rassemblement national à saint siège
parce qu apparemment de bonne solution
c'est à dire qu'on voit à la majorité au
sein de l'assemblée nationale soit
finalement le rn s'oppose totalement et
vote avec la nuque et une partie des
républicains sur certains textes et dans
ce cas là finalement le gouvernement
peut être en minorité comme milla n'a
qu'une majorité relative soit le renne
vote
certains textes où certains articles et
là effectivement la majorité et le
gouvernement sont accusés finalement une
forme d' alliance de circonstance avec
le parti de marine le pen nous parliez
tout à l'heure de baiser de la mort
c'est exactement ça on sent qu'ils
savent pas trop quelle ligne adoptée
officiellement la ligne c'est on n'ira
pas chercher leur voix mais en même
temps ils veulent voter pour nous on
peut pas les empêcher de voter pour nous
ça fait penser un peu à ce qui s'était
passé dans les régions notamment en 98
tout à droite certains à dire non non il
n'y a pas eu d'accord ils ont voté pour
nous se rappelle notamment charles
millon en région rhône alpes et puis
c'est un petit peu ce que dit la gauche
aussi et c'est un petit peu
effectivement aussi ce qu'on ce qu'on
voit à gauche et c'est aussi ce qu'a
expliqué le fait qu elisabeth bande ne
sollicite pas la confiance des
parlementaires quand vous en parliez
avec son entourage ou avec l'entourage
des manuels macron à l'elysée et il
m'expliquait que clairement il a elle
fait tous les calculs il avait pris des
cuts et par député il avait le sentiment
que ça pouvait passer qu'elle avait une
chance à ces fortes d'obtenir la
majorité mais leurs craintes énorme
c'était qu'elle ne l'obtienne que grâce
notamment à l'abstention des députés du
rassemblement national évidemment ça
aurait pas fait bon genre et donc ils
n'ont pas voulu prendre ce risque là est
d'ailleurs derrière ça il ya évidemment
sa stratégie finement préparé par le par
leur assemblée nationale we are déjà sur
ce texte en particulier qu'on voit pas
ce que le pouvoir d'achat marine le pen
en a parlé depuis des semaines depuis
des mois tout au long de l'élection
présidentielle et donc quand elle dit la
semaine dernière sur rtl ce texte on l'a
levé il est pas parfait mais c'est mieux
que rien c'est pour vraiment continuer
d'apparaître en tout cas c'est ce
qu'elle dit comme le parti du pouvoir
d'achat ensuite on le disait ses 89
députés même elle n'imaginait pas en
avoir autant donc elle est bien décidée
à en faire quelque chose c'est
exactement cela après sept des
diaboliques et finalement elle veut s'en
servir pour s'institutionnaliser dans le
paysage politique a montré que ces
députés finalement il serait absolument
comme les autres et derrière ça y est
effectivement un objectif c'est
d'apparaître comme l'alternance à
emmanuel macron dans cinq ans et on le
voit même physiquement au sein du palais
bourbon et à le petit groupe des députés
les républicains et puis allez 89 du
rassemblement national à côté et
effectivement quand vous échanger avec
les députés des républicains c'est ce
qu'ils vous disent ils nous disent nous
notre crainte clairement c'est qu aux
yeux des français finalement ils
deviennent le rpr des années 80 90 et
qu'il nous dévore tout cru jusqu'au
dernier député et jean pierre mignard ce
rassemblement national là bas il se
combat pas de la même manière que le
front national
parce qu'il faut toujours regarder du
côté de l'italie il se passe toujours
des choses en italie était un
laboratoire ce pays et c'est vrai que
monsieur salvini il se trouve avec le
parti la gauche démocratique c'est très
vaste un tout le monde un vrai bien
c'est une habitude qui à la fin va
l'emporter on parle même maintenant
l'euphrate et icade italia qui serait en
mesure peut-être effectivement de damer
le pion à monsieur draghi c'est pour ça
que je pense que le conseil or emmanuel
macron et toujours il voit toujours les
italiens est toujours
attaché une grande importance à
peut-être que l'on va avec ce nouveau
parlement peut-être qu'on va vers une
petit à petit une sorte de situation à
l'italienne
si la majorité elle-même n'est plus
tellement sur des choix qu'elle doit
faire on voit ici d'ailleurs qu'il ya
120 ans la majorité il ya quelquefois
des embauches sur l'essieu de la taxe
sur les super profits deuxièmement sur
la position vis-à-vis de madame cayeux
c'est bien ça là-dessus il n'y a pas
d'accord bon donc il peut y avoir au
sein de la majorité des jeunes ipade
retour d'âge ou des retours de gauche
mais en tout cas jusqu'où va-t-on aller
je pense que madame le pen l'a
parfaitement compris l air la venue a
compris que même y avoir une sorte de
course en sac entre lrn lequel ira le
plus vite et le plus loin pour faire
refonder refonder une majorité à
l'intérieur de l'assemblée différente de
celle que l'on voit compartimentée
aujourd'hui je pense que ça se passait
des choses tout à fait importante et
donc la refondation comme vous le disiez
griondins d'une grande droite et puis il
y aura la gauche finalement on retourne
avec le deuxième et dernier mandat des
mâles et mâcon on va retourner aux
fondamentaux avec une droite
reconstituer et une gauche voilà un nom
pas voilà c'est ça la vie ce sera le mot
de la fin de ce premier débat merci à
tous d'y avoir participé dans